hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to ask mkbhd number 26. still
doing one every month so this is the one
for march 2018 and for those of you
who've been paying attention is a bit of
a special upload or episode
this is the thousandth video i've ever
uploaded to this channel if you include
the live streams and things we've ever
done this is number one thousand we've
ever posted and it's coming also around
the time of the 10 year anniversary of
the day i signed up for youtube so a
thousand videos in 10 years
it seems like it's been a lot faster
than a decade but that's where we're at
so i asked you guys your questions on
twitter you had plenty i kind of asked
about like if you had questions about
the last 10 years of videos but most of
you just ignore that so we'll just get
right into what you did ask so first up
is what do you feel you've improved on
most and least over a thousand videos
um i can say
noise control
have not improved noise control so i
know i've improved uh efficiency the
most like i've gotten better at editing
videos at shooting at the whole
organization process of putting a video
together so if you give me a day with
all this equipment in 2009 versus a day
with this equipment now the video i'd
make today would be way better just
because i'm faster at editing and better
at all this stuff um
improved the least is a tough like that
would imply like i have done this well
from the start so i don't really know if
i can think of anything the thing that
comes to mind that's changed the least
is probably my language i keep i've said
dope and crispy and words like that from
the beginning so maybe that's something
that's improved the least at what age
did you upload your first video and what
did your parents say about it
so uh hi mom dad if you're watching uh i
was 14 in 2009 when i uploaded the first
tech videos just you know got a laptop
for high school started making that
stuff purchased a new laptop cooler uh i
didn't tell my parents for a while so i
was just kind of uploading these things
like making videos in my room under the
radar putting them on the internet
probably not the best idea as a little
kid but it's gone a long way since then
and it's a little easier uh but when
they did find out they were just kind of
like
all right this isn't the worst thing our
kid could be doing in his spare time so
i guess uh keep it up and they've been
very supportive since then so thanks how
many minutes people watch how many
minutes have people watched your most
popular video and total minutes of all
videos
uh so actually an interesting fact is
the most popular video or most viewed
video on the channel is a different
video than it used to be it's the iphone
10 unboxing it used to be a different
iphone video as a matter of fact
probably seven out of the top 10 most
viewed videos on this channel are not
just apple videos or iphone videos but
it just it's past 10 million views and
that
has turned into
32 million 374 255 minutes watched
of me taking an iphone 10 out of the box
markling says if i beat you at rocket
league can you upload a 21x9 video
in 24p
okay a lot of little nuggets in there so
number one okay mark if you're
challenging me to rocket league i'm
assuming coming out of the woodwork
you're probably pretty good so we should
probably come up with some sort of uh
prize if i beat you also and then of
course like uploading a 21x9 video we've
talked about like shrinking aspect
ratios to two to one which is a little
less drastic but i think is a change you
can reasonably make in 2018 but 21x9 is
a bit more extreme
and more interesting and more drastic of
a change for one video wouldn't be crazy
but i could see
uploading two to one videos
in the near future most of the screens
in our lives like these these monitors
and tvs
and desktops and laptops even are mostly
still 16x9 so it makes sense to keep
uploading 16x9 but obviously our phones
are changing that and there's a lot of
two to one aspect ratios a lot of super
wides uh people like super wide desktops
now so it's interesting considering
maybe uploading two to one videos in the
future let me know what you guys think
about that but then also uh 24 fps
i've just never been a 24 fps kind of
guy what is going to be your next big
step up in the filming game
possibly robots
that will mean more when you see the
next video but stay tuned for that this
is the year cp3 is finally going to get
a championship uh it sure looks like it
and if you look back at an older q a
video from a couple months ago like the
preseason before the nba season started
i was wearing a houston rockets hoodie
and i dropped cp3 as my favorite player
on the houston rockets and why i follow
that team
and since then they've been the best
record in the conference they've won 31
out of their last 33 games and they look
like they're gonna be a one seed and
hold home court and probably beat the
warriors
not saying i caused that but uh clearly
some good vibes there why is the nokia
3310 the greatest phone of all time
sent from a nokia 3310
all right austin can you tweet from the
nokia 3310 really this phone is the go
of course i have one this phone is a
goat uh
the same way that tiger woods michael
jordan
they just kind of you don't really even
think about it you just kind of know
that this is the best it's ever been but
then it gets kind of weird when they
like come back out of retirement and
they're not the same as they used to be
so you just kind of pay more attention
to the weight what this is this is
obviously the greatest phone of all time
common code wants to know about the red
hydrogen one status
uh i am not authorized to update you on
that status right now i'm not authorized
all right here's one from the subreddit
is do you regret making any of your
videos which ones
and why
so generally
not really no uh there's a couple
instances though that come to mind one
of them was a couple years ago in the
college days so you guys have generally
been pretty positive about uh you know
showcasing you know working with
different brands in the studio and in
videos but before any of that uh we
actually made a gopro video this is just
me as a college kid with a gopro trying
to figure out what to do with it and we
put it on a dog and did a video of like
a day in the life of a dog so that dog
was mac and you may remember him from
that video i'll link it below if you
haven't seen it he's really into
guarding the door um but we had a little
ending of that video which was just the
you know the shot on gopro animation
that you usually see at the end of gopro
videos i thought it would be cool to add
that to the end of our video with mac
now i didn't work with gopro on that
video or anything it just felt like a
natural way to end that video and the
comments on that video tore it apart
because they all thought oh you got
sponsored but you didn't say it was
sponsored but then you made this ad for
gopro obviously now i get it it looks
like an ad when you end the video the
way all the ads end but uh
i guess i regret adding that animation
rory is very transparent about working
with brands though so and i want to be
even more obvious about it in the future
the way we should so you'll always know
like i've always added it to the
description when a device was provided
by the people
who make it so that kind of thing is
always going to be there but
yeah that's something that comes to mind
all right another tweet uh what was the
most enjoyable video you have ever
created
which is it's pretty general but that
actually got me thinking about the least
enjoyable
shooting conditions i've ever had to
deal with in making a tech video now i'm
not like an action photographer like
running through the wilderness i'm not
devin supertramp it doesn't happen very
often that we get difficult shooting
conditions
but as you can probably tell i'm also
pretty obsessed with making videos look
good and tech events and other youtubers
can probably attest to this tech events
especially new smartphone launches
generally have the worst lighting the
worst shooting conditions
imaginable i'm talking like purple
green lighting like spotlights
everywhere harsh lighting shadows
floors that move when you try to put a
tripod on them like really annoying
difficult to make videos in conditions
and i'm not even naming names there but
i think like if you ask any other tech
youtuber they'll probably have that same
experience at some point but
apples
always
seem to be ideal like there haven't been
youtubers at apple events until pretty
recently but it's pretty obvious when
you go to one that they think about the
photographers and the news channels and
the videographers that go there and now
also the youtubers and the one that
comes to mind when i'm talking about
this is the iphone 8 launch which we
shot that in a room where they brought
all the press back there but it was
literally lit like the entire ceiling
was just soft boxes just huge
white beautifully soft soft boxes and
everything we shot in there was
effortlessly like no reflections well
lit beautiful i that's the kind of thing
i hope for when i go to a tech event but
it almost never happens uh have you
thought about making a second channel
this is a thing uh that definitely comes
up in the the careers of a lot of
youtubers second channels vlog channels
behind the scenes separate channels
podcast channels
um
i've obviously put everything that i
make on this channel which is why we're
at a thousand videos but i haven't
really had a need to
yet it might come up
it might be a future thing but i haven't
really needed a second channel at this
point oh i like this one who is your
biggest inspiration for your videos or
your work
um
i think you probably were expecting me
to say like a couple other youtubers
names this may be going to sound dumb
but
apple's videography here we go sound
like an apple fanboy in this video but
apple videos their commercials their
launch event videos
are
incredible now it's clearly it's made by
teams of people it's made over a long
period of time and they have like time
with the products it's clearly
composition of both real footage and
renders so there's a lot of impossible
shots in those videos that i could never
get but every time i watch an apple
video or an apple commercial or if you
just go on our youtube channel and just
observe the sound design and the
lighting and the editing in those videos
that's the kind of stuff
i hope to be able to live up to someday
also fun fact apparently apple shoots
all their commercials
in 30 fps so there's that also you've
probably noticed we've started getting a
little bit back into interviews
generally lately having neil degrasse
tyson on the channel as a guest which
has made me appreciate interviews more
generally and people who do really good
interviews like oh hey a youtuber sean
evans on first we feast on hot ones
really good interviews
really
really good interviews and then what
does what does the k stand for uh
hashtag thousand video special
the k in mkbhd
i think we'll save for another milestone
how about that
we'll leave it at that so that's been it
thank you guys for watching thanks to
those of you who have stuck around for
a decade a thousand videos a
ridiculously long time and supported the
channel and shared the videos uh up to
this point and uh hopefully we keep
improving all of the things that are in
the videos to the point where you'll
want to keep watching them until the
next one thanks for watching talk to you
guys later peace